thank you
[Music]
there's a special uh sushi roll
and it does it's it was sold out of a uh
restaurant in Montana of all places wow
this special sushi roll has since since
its debut has killed two people and
poisoned at least 30. is it the um the
puffer fishing food it's not Fugu and
it's not what's Fugu puffer fish oh so I
guess I just was redundant
for a second
wow dude
are so dramatic yeah you're being
dramatic Walter I didn't say compliments
yeah it's gross
okay anyway yeah a special role they
call it what do you think was in it to
hurt all these people
Colleen said E coli River
fish laid out for a month yeah yeah yeah
um it was some something parasitic I
don't know parasitic huh
is it something that it's actually like
quite normal
um it's not as weird as it sounds it's
peanuts is it fish from like the one of
the Lakes it's not even fish ah peanuts
is it raw is it raw beef is it like the
seaweed no it's not even meat it's not
even meat oh [__] so what could it be
seaweed or a rice cyanide uh it's not
like a synthetic element either it's
like uh it's an ingredient that that
could have been in anything
I've never heard of it but they say um
they believe
it's um it says the restaurant said in
an Instagram post they believe the
common ingredient was cultured moral
mushrooms imported from China mushrooms
yeah okay
that is one phrase that should never go
together what imported from China
cultured mushrooms and then what was the
word before mushroom Morel more yeah
cultured moral mushrooms imported from
China that should never go together it's
these things so it's a fungus oh that
sounds good what the you freak what do
you mean people just die from eating
this thing but it looks good no yeah it
looks dangerous when you boil it when
you boil it you know China's they're
famous right now for um what is it
counterfeiting truffle mushrooms it's
their lab like they're lab grown because
you know truffles have to be underground
truffles do you are you a fan of
truffles I can't honestly say I've had
real troubles because maybe like the
ones I had were fake from from your
country
um
but the whole dramatic again the ones
I've had
flavored I haven't had it with sushi
um they'll cut a little piece of it and
put it on and it complements very well
yeah it's really good it's quite nice do
you care if it's fake or not oh my God
you know if I can't if I can't tell I
don't care but at the point if I've had
it enough where I could tell then I will
care yeah that's like wagyu like how do
you know
because of the paper that they'll yeah
yeah yeah about the places they'll show
you the paper
I look at the paper I go you know what I
can make that like I can make I could be
crazy laminated yeah dude it sounds like
a really uh rough way to go it says that
like one of the people who died and says
that they were experiencing extreme
symptoms within an hour and uh uh went
into cardiac arrest followed by multiple
organ failures oh and from what I
remembered like someone told me that
organ failure is like one of the most
painful ways to die oh that sucks yeah
because you feel everything it's like
you just feel everything stop working
from the inside yeah that sucks oh yeah
I feel honestly I do feel bad for people
that died because I got sick however
okay if you read a cultured Laurel
mushroom imported from China and that
doesn't cause concern or pause it's
showing them fall
out inside baseball these are people is
it their fault yeah they're in Montana
or is it the restaurants for seeing that
and being like let's put that in the
role because morale I cannot disagree
with you
is it is it like an alley or is it
actually a toxic or like what is it I
don't think the mushroom quiet innately
kills people yeah
yeah they said that it's a common yeah
it's a common ingredient though that's
what causes pause because what else is
called what's wrong with Chinese yeah
yeah yeah
we don't have enough time
but like if you look at cultured things
yogurt you know
a battery it's not bad I'm gonna eat it
for sure
because culture.com you have to wait for
it to kind of like what's the word um
ferment yeah ferment oh okay so it
doesn't mean that it's like you know
it's the mushroom has culture it means
like you know it traveled a bit yeah
but that culture that to me would cause
pause I don't I don't eat mushrooms I
don't want mushrooms but like mushrooms
are Cod bot and they're imported by
China be like no hell no so is it mostly
the cultured part or the China part
dude if one was taken out give them
spaces what would it be if I wasn't so
fearful of the throwing the throwing
down the sunglasses I would I'm just
gonna say the culture part but if I
wasn't if I wasn't afraid I must have
imported by China
I did transfer to Japan so I'm guessing
they kept it on the menu
apparently
yeah I want to know is like what caused
it because if it's a normal ingredient
was there something in the mushroom like
another fungus that latched on to it
like what here's a little bit of a
variable the two people that died where
were on the older Spectrum okay of those
ages so cam thinks it's their fault
right so old people can't eat mushrooms
all right what's the second one well
they're immunocompromised probably maybe
yeah so there was some sort of bacteria
maybe that was on the mushroom because I
mean like up to at least 30 people were
poisoned but they did pull through or
poisoned yeah like they were affected
the same way as the two people that died
but the two people just couldn't
get it because there's so many species
of mushroom that one could look like
that but it's actually slightly
genetically different to some of the
Chinese guy yeah the Chinese guy was
like oh whatever what the hell it's the
same thing
oh my God
I'm so sorry
take it back I am so sorry
[Laughter]
I gotta say this though for the for the
Japanese people right now that are
listening that are like up in arms yeah
it's not sushi what do you mean yeah
there's no raw fish in there yeah
um so it's not like California rolls
aren't Sushi either yeah this is just
some
montananian concoction
that's meant to be yeah what's up with
you yeah so like I just want to put it
out there so people love Japan
it's an interesting choice of uh sushi
right a roll not my first Burger it's
not even Sushi yeah yeah it technically
isn't sushi what is it but it does suck
that like it's a rice casserole I I feel
I feel for them a little bit like
whenever because Sushi gets such a bad
rap still am I like stupid yeah like
Americans are like sushi most people
especially with the clients that I talk
to yeah none of them really like seafood
like seafood is still like I'm so used
to like my friend group and my bubble of
people that I like to hang out with like
seafood yeah let's go let's get the
oysters let's get whatever you know but
then most people I think especially in
America yeah just don't like fish and
they have a negative you know what it is
but also too like their variety of foods
that they eat or like not them I think I
know why I think I know it's because the
people that don't like seafood that are
living in places with bad Seafood that's
probably all they of course Quality
Seafood is so delicious exactly but good
seafood shouldn't be fishy yeah I mean
you shouldn't yeah that means it's
actually cooking it is hard to have an
entry-level homie that can show you the
good TV to level you up
they're probably going honestly they're
probably going to like Javier's all you
can eat sushi this restaurant's called
Dave's Sushi exactly and then they go
and they go hey I had sushi it was like
mushrooms it was gross like I'm not
gonna eat sushi anymore good yeah
exactly I don't remember the more like
Midwest you go there's just chances are
the Sushi's not gonna be as good yeah
like just the chances not even have
sushi restaurants [__] okay kinda and
that's fine yeah that's fine especially
if people are dying in your business
yeah yeah does this sound how many days
like was it one day that all 30 people
were affected or was it like over the
course of like a month I well the people
who died did die days after but um is
that batch but what I mean is like did
they eat did all 30 people eat the same
day or was it like 30 people no it
wasn't the same day so they kept serving
it but they know but food poisoning is
very difficult because it is hard to
like Trace what yeah which thing it is
and then once they've found the common
and denominator being all these people
had eaten at Dave Sushi and ordered that
special role
probably kind of I feel like that's kind
of how you guys
like how
I think it also
when you go to like when you go to the
ICU or you go to the emergency it's in
your chart yeah like all the information
you gave like oh I ate this like this is
and then once that all starts to
correlate then they can like the life
lesson here is don't go to a restaurant
where the name like if they're using a
personal name isn't from the culture
you don't want to
alongside Yuk's Burgers like I'm not
gonna do that actually
is
yeah yeah
[Music]
he's another folk hero yeah Jet Li play
both won't and Wong's Pizza exactly
why I gotta represent my people well
what about La Pizza Loca that's freaking
ask me if I've been there have you been
there no I have not you're uncultured
but if we want to stay away from the
Asian thing like Pierre's Pizza
you might go to pierce pizza but you
won't for sushi specifically you're not
gonna go to Giuseppe's Sushi no
or like yamamoto's Pizzeria I might go
to Yama mama
was in Japan I would go but it was in
Montana I'll say this anytime there's a
Japanese person behind something I mean
[Music]